when Apple announced that you can now
get an 8 core processor and the new 2019
macbook pro the first thought that came
into everyone's mind is that it's
definitely gonna thermal throttle if the
six core macbook pro did so we're gonna
find out if that's true by running our
classic Cinebench stress test on both
the new MacBook Pro with the 2.3
gigahertz eight core processor
32 gigs of RAM and Vega 20 graphics as
well as on our similarly configured in
price 2018 model with the 2.6 gigahertz
six core i7 processor the reason it's
not the six core i9 processor is because
we saw literally zero gains in video
editing compared to the i7 and we expect
to see the same results with a new eight
core hence why we didn't pay an extra
two hundred dollars for the faster eight
core processor what we're gonna do is
run cinnamon jar 25 times back-to-back
to ensure that the system heats up and
the fans stabilize the temps shortly
after starting our first run the CPU
boosts up to four point three nine
gigahertz nowhere near the advertised
4.8 gigahertz turbo boost speed which
isn't a surprise because that number is
rated off just one core out of eight
running by itself with temps under 50
degrees Celsius the clock speed then
lowers down to around three point three
gigahertz just before the temps reach 99
degrees as soon as this happens the
wattage drops to sixty the temps
instantly shoot down to 90 degrees in
the clock speed is now sticking to
around 3.0 gigahertz the temp slowly
starts picking up again and stays at
around 97 degrees while the clock speed
hovers around 2.9 gigahertz and so we
finished the first run with a score of
3096
before instantly re running the test
again just for comparison the $5000 base
iMac pro scores around 3700 points in
this test starting the second run the
CPU spikes to a lower 4.3 one gigahertz
before coming back down to the same 2.9
gigahertz clock speed range
unlike the first run the fans are now at
full blast so it's able to keep the
clock speed higher at around 3.0
gigahertz at the same 97 degrees
tempering
now finishing with an even higher 3160
once core starting the third run the CPU
spikes up to only 3.6 5 gigahertz
showing the effect temps
have on turbo boost speeds now here we
notice something very interesting the
clock speed is able to stay at around
three gigahertz while the temps are
sitting at or lower 94 to 95 degrees but
out of nowhere the CPU clocks down to
2.9 gigahertz even though it doesn't
need to
since the temps aren't too high in fact
they go as low as 91 degrees with plenty
of thermal Headroom for faster clock
speeds but it doesn't ever go above 3.0
gigahertz almost like it's being
intentionally limited the third run
finishes with a 3125 score the fourth
run spikes up to 3.7 gigahertz turbo
boost so it seems like the system's
thermals have stabilized we can now see
that the temperature stays at 93 degrees
while at 2.9 gigahertz and 95 degrees
while at 3.0 gigahertz now completely
stabilized the fourth run scored three
thousand 154 points in the fifth scored
three thousand one hundred forty-seven
making for a five run average score of
three thousand one hundred and thirty
six now before we draw some conclusions
and thoughts from this let's quickly
talk about the results from the 2018
MacBook Pro basically every single run
hit around 4.03 to 4.04 gigahertz Peak
turbo boost before coming down to around
three point one to three point three
gigahertz before finally stabilizing at
around three point four to three point
oh eight gigahertz attempts ranging from
around 96 to 97 degrees and
interestingly we didn't see temps
randomly going down to 91 or 92 degrees
like we did on the 2019 Pro each run was
also very consistent and scored exactly
2425 points every time comparing both of
them we see that the 2019 model hit a
much higher four point three nine
gigahertz turbo boost
but the stabilized clock speed was lower
at around 2.9 to 3.0 gigahertz compared
to 3.0 four to 3.0 8 gigahertz
however the stabilized temps were lower
staying between 93 and 95 degrees
compared to 96 and 97 degrees this shows
us that Apple decided to keep the temps
a bit lower on the new model instead of
slightly turning up the power to hit
around 97 degrees I read through some
forums and some users mentioned that the
high
of previous MacBook Pros could have been
wearing down the components in the
butterfly keyboard so if that's true it
would make sense why Apple would want
attempts to stay lower and it could
actually fix the keyboard issues once
and for all the best part is that even
though temps were lower than they could
have been we still got an average score
that's 30% higher than the 2018 MacBook
Pro so we get more power with cooler
temps at the same exact price snazzy
labs tested the new a core MacBook Pro
and he found that Apple seems to have
set a full load clock speed target which
instead of turning up the clock speed
whenever there's extra thermal Headroom
the machine would slow down the fans for
a quieter experience he also replaced
the thermal paste with liquid metal and
didn't find much of a difference stating
that the 2019 MacBook Pro features much
better thermal paste than previous
MacBook Pros this definitely shows in
our testing as the 2019 macbook pro
idled at only 35 degrees Celsius
compared to 45 degrees with that 2018
model now that's a huge difference we
also tested Cinebench R 20 using a
single thread to see the difference in
performance and we saw that the 2019 Pro
hit a maximum of 4 point 5 gigahertz
turbo boost compared to four point one
seven on the 2018 pro and we scored four
hundred and sixty-six points compared to
four hundred and twenty two so not only
do we get two extra cores but each core
is faster as well so let's answer our
original question the 2019 eight core
macbook pro obviously thermal throttles
right no it actually fixes the
throttling issues from before performing
much better while at lower temps which
may possibly even fix the keyboard
issues at the same time if you're
thankful that we ran these tests and
you're thinking of buying a 2019 MacBook
Pro for yourself smash that like button
and use the links in the description
below to help support this channel make
sure yourself by clicking that circle
above and check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]